salut comme tous les jours pendant
trente jours cet été je vous donne une
énigme avant de vous donner l'énigme du
jour je vous donne la réponse de
l'énigme d'hier et si vous l'avez pas vu
foncer l'avoir puisque je vais donner la
réponse maintenant il vaut mieux que
vous voyez l'énigme d'abord de quelle
couleur et l'ours mais il est blanc
c'est un ours blanc parce que notre
chasseur est au pôle nord
obligatoirement au pôle nord au pôle sud
d'ailleurs alors je sais qu'il ya pas
d'ours au pôle nord au pôle sud
on sait que dans les régions froides ce
sont des ours blancs comment aussi qu'il
a un des deux pôles parce qu'il fait 10
km vers le sud 10 km vers l'est 10 km
vers le nord
donc il devrait pas retomber sur le même
point on sait qu'il retombe sur le même
point puisque l'ours n'a pas bougé par
contre comme on sait qu'il a avec sa
boussole il fait 10 km vers le sud
10 km vers l'est et 10 km vers le nord
et il va faire un triangle puisque le
pôle nord indiquent le nord énigme donc
très intéressante mais peut-être pas
aussi intéressante que l'énigme
d'aujourd'hui dans cette septième
énigmes nous allons imaginer que nous
sommes au moyen âge dans un château
fictifs et il ya un roi qui est mourant
il appelle à son chevet ses deux fils
leur dis mes fils vous voyez à l'horizon
l'église de la ville voisine
bon ok là c'est plutôt la défense est
bien celui d'entre vous dont le cheval
arrivera en dernier à l'église héritera
de tout mon immense fortune les deux
fils font ça l'écurie et file au triple
galop dans la ville voisine
ils vont le plus rapidement possible à
l'église ma question est pourquoi ils se
dépêchent comme ça
cherchez bien vous avez 24 heures pour
trouver comme d'habitude vous donnerai
la réponse dans la vidéo de demain
profiter du soleil passer un bel été
n'oubliez pas de vous abonner à la
chaîne et rendez vous demain à 17h ciao